In the last few days there has been a respiratory peak,
i.e.
an increase in respiratory symptoms that we
have been able to show in our family friends,
well-known co-workers,
which have been a frequent reason for consultation in health centers.
Among the causing viruses we find influenza type a h one n one is the
respiratory incitial virus and of course the COVID 19 that arrived to stay
in the environment and therefore will continue to generate respiratory peaks.
The most important thing in this situation are preventive measures.
First of all,
we must ensure that everyone has a complete vaccination schedule,
i.e.
that they are up to date.
Second,
practice respiratory hygiene and cough
labeling if we have respiratory symptoms,
use masks,
avoid crowded places,
congested crowds where there is little ventilation,
and also try not to leave the house if we have
respiratory symptoms to prevent complications.
people.